what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so sometimes I like to let my
imagination run wild and just talk about
crazy things things that I think are
really really cool or really really
interesting things that would basically
like like capture my attention or the
very least is not just me running over a
comic book story and so I want to try
something different here I want to talk
about a character and I might turn this
into a series characters that are too
powerful for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right like too powerful for
Marvel movies because I've been thinking
about this recently and there's a lot of
characters of Marvel Comics that are
just broken right like they're just
insanely overpowered this is gonna be
like a weird thing in this one I want to
talk about Mad Jim Jasper's all right
because everybody knows I love
Majumdar's I love the character and I'm
C I'm not I'm not really shooting for
views I'm just shooting for like
characters that I think that I that I
want to talk about here so Jim Jasper's
was due he was so broken I mean he was
he was he was so broken okay so so what
you had and Marvel comics back in the
day is you had something called the
omniversal development court and you
still have it to this day it ran all the
way up to the encourages so the way this
worked is in in Marvel Comics you've got
like a multi-faceted system when it
comes to the multiverse on the surface
what you see are like multiple universes
right and that seems like that's it like
there's all these different universes
you know you have the main Marvel
Universe which is called earth-616 and
then you have like all these other
universes that are out there
the ultimate universe a universe where
where deadpool gets the Venom symbiote a
universe where spider-man never gets rid
of the venom suit a universe where Jean
Grey becomes the Phoenix and kills
everyone I mean you have like all these
different various universes out there
and so from there it starts breaking
down into kind of like a hierarchy and a
system of management is how that works
you have for example the custodian of
the multiverse a being that exists to
make sure the multiverse doesn't
collapse in on itself
you've got the The Living Tribunal which
is a judge of the multiverse to make
sure that like magical energies of
various neo mystical energies that
exists are not imbalanced so like
there's not like two doctor Strange's in
a particular universe or something along
those lines and then from there you have
what's called the Omni virtual
development court and the Omni versatile
development court exists for the purpose
of monitoring every single universe in
the multiverse and saying okay at this
point along the line mutants should rise
to power or should should like begin the
Oh manifesting their powers at this
point along the line a Captain America
should exist at this point along the
line there should be an irony there
should be an Avengers team it doesn't
mean that like Captain America will be
Steve Rogers it doesn't mean that like
Iron Man will be Tony Stark it just
means some
along the line these various characters
should begin popping up which is why if
you go and look at every single like
what if story alternate reality story
whatever the case may be you will always
see that the superheroes that you know
appearing in some former fashion like in
Jonathon Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers during the collapse of the
multiverse there was a point where the
Illuminati so like Reed Richards iron
iron man beast Hank McCoy and like name
of the Submariner and black panther
there was a point where like they
started looking at these different
universes like Jonathan Hickman started
showing us these different universes
that were being destroyed by the
incursions and they had one called the
Great Society which was basically the DC
Universe inside the Marvel multiverse
and what you had was like this whole new
era of superheroes like sun-god which
was basically Superman yeah basically
stand in for like Wonder Woman the flash
Green Lantern and so on and so forth and
what ended up happening here is where
none of the superheroes that you knew of
which is to say Wolverine Captain
America Iron Man where none of them were
there they were tied into it in the
sense that like the Great Society rose
to power because a massive Cataclysm
took place on earth where all the
superheroes were killed like all the all
the Marvel superheroes are basically
killed off and I want to say it was like
the kree-skrull war that led to like the
deaths of of them all and that led to
the rise of the Great Society but they
were still there like they they you know
they were there in some form or fashion
that's why you always see that and so
once what what do you have in the
omniversal Development Court is you have
a woman by the name of Saturn II that in
another universe and I want to say it
was earth 238 as the numerical
designation for it there were no
superheroes on earth like Captain
America and none of those guys mutants
didn't rise to power and none of that
stuff with that well they were there but
they had all been killed off but the
omniversal Development Court didn't know
that all they knew was that on this
universe on this only on this earth in
this universe
none of the superheroes exist and there
was no indication they ever did and so
the result was that they basically went
to go kind of poke around now around the
same time that happened a character by
the name of Brian Braddock also known as
Captain Britain had been sent by a guy
named Merlin to go to this earth and
face off against the person who
annihilated all those heroes and so
basically by two different measures the
Omni Brussels Development Court and
Captain Britain responded to that
universe at the same time and what you
ended up having what ended up finding
out was there was there's a guy on that
planet named Mad Jim Jasper's or at
least just Jim Jasper's but he's called
mad Jim Jasper's and he had the ability
to control the fundamental forces of the
universe itself and so what he did is he
basically created a being called a fury
and the fury was kind of like this
robotic organism that had the ability to
adapt to any power and so
if you were to like attack it with super
strength it would instantly register
what your power was and then adapt to it
before you could attack and it used that
ability to annihilate every single
superhero on the face of the planet and
when the question was asked of Jim
Jasper's why he did that he said well I
just wanted to eliminate the competition
is all that was now eventually Captain
Britain faces off against that version
of Jim Jasper's who's like just really
really powerful but when the Omni
Russell Development Court gets there
they're like okay there's no superheroes
here whatsoever and there's no
indication they ever existed here so
we're going to initiate something called
the push and the push was basically the
Omni Russell Development Court sank
we're going to jumpstart the evolution
of people so like we're gonna fast-track
the the rise of mutants basically like
the genes exist because the Celestials
put them there they just don't seem to
have manifested for some reason so we're
going to initiate the push and we're
gonna bring those genes out basically
like mutant powers are gonna start
popping up everywhere
and Jim Josh first took this as a threat
and the result was that he initiated
something called the Jaspers war and the
Jasper's Worf was essentially like this
energy that emanated off of Jim Jasper's
himself that started distorting and
warping everything around him and at
that point it was like it was like
escaping a collapsing tunnel right it
was like we gotta go so like everybody
left right like like the omniversal
development court left saturnine left
Captain Britain left they all bailed out
as fast as they could because what was
happening was this this Jasper's warp
was emanating all throughout the
entirety of earth and then spreading
beyond earth into the solar system and
then into the rest of the galaxy and
then into the universe and was gonna
spill out into the multiverse and so
this was a guy who had the ability to
basically distort the entirety of the
multiverse itself now because of the
fact that saturnine was believed to have
been a failure because of the fact that
counter britain was yanked back by
merlin what this meant was that the the
earth 238 universe was annihilated
innocent tired he was totally destroyed
by the omniversal Development Court
completely and totally wiped clean and
so it was just this giant empty void
that had never really existed in the
first place as kind of how it was
treated and so from there Captain
Britain is sent back to his main earth
and then he's told by Merlin this was a
test this is this was to see how you
would prepare or how you would be able
to cope with someone like like Jim
Jasper's and the question by Kath from
Captain Britain is why a Merlin said
because your earth has it has a Jim
Jasper's of its own and he's more
powerful than that one and so like
Captain Britain has to go and face off
against the main Marvel Universe of Jim
Jasper's and that's when you end up
seeing just how powerful his character
really is so there comes a point when
Captain Britain travels to
to wherever it is that the Prime
Minister of England resides that because
that's like Jim Josh was the prime
minister at the time there was a point
where where Captain Britain travels to
to wherever the Prime Minister is and to
is to his office basically and as soon
as he opens the door and walks in where
you would expect it to be in office it's
just like this endless void of empty
space and Jim Jasper's is just like this
massive beam that probably stands 5,000
feet tall who's just sitting in a chair
and just starts toying with Captain
Britain like he snaps his fingers and
Captain Britain's like a little kid in a
classroom and then he snaps his fingers
and he's doing something else like he's
so hopelessly outmatched like this with
a snap of his fingers the entire
universal space within that office is
expanded to an exponential rate and then
like money manipulated into being any
number of things and it's just an insane
amount of power like like that kind of
person is like God level power and so
ultimately like there's not even Captain
Britain who wins what you end up finding
out is that when the original 238
universe was destroyed their fury
survived because it adapted to the
destruction of its own universe and then
the fury basically picks up on Jim
Jasper's because his powers are so
extreme the use of his abilities are
sending like shock waves into the
multiverse people and other universes
are feeling the effects of what he's
doing not in the sense that like their
world is being destroyed but in the
sense that like those who were attuned
enough can pick up on the energy
signature of a guy like on the other
side of the multiverse which is just how
powerful he was and so the fury hones in
on that signal and then travels directly
to Jim Jasper's and starts adapting to
his powers and so like in this battle
between Jim Jasper's and the fury the
entire basis of the universe itself
starts getting reworked and rearranged
and twisted and manipulated and
distorted through like all forms of
madness and then eventually the fury
realizes the only way to defeat Jim
Jasper's is to move him away because
what Jasper's does is he doesn't
actually like create things right he
can't create fire all he can do is
manipulate fire so he's just controlling
the universe he's not creating a
universe which is one of the big
differences between someone like Jim
Jasper's and like Matthew Malloy or like
Franklin Richards or something like that
and so the fury takes Jim Jasper's and
teleports him to the void that was earth
2:38 and there's nothing for him to
manipulate and then in turn incinerates
Jim Jasper's and that's the end of him
it's kind of a caveat it's kind of a way
just sort of in the story and it works
for what it was but like you're talking
about it being this insanely powerful I
mean Jim Jasper's against like Thanos in
the Infinity Gauntlet if it was earth to
the 238 Jim Jasper's probably not if
it's the earth-616 Jim Jasper's I would
say probably so the only way that I
think
danos could win would be because he
controls the time stone and in like Jim
Jasper's cannot control time he can't
like send people back and forth through
time and even then like like Jim
Jasper's is controlling the the forces
of the universe but so is Santos Santos
can't create a universe using the
Infinity Gauntlet so their powers seem
to be equal in that regard I don't know
that's not the top of my head I could
probably do some like hardcore research
and do some poking around and like you
were comparing and try a store like
break it down but I'm not going to and
so like because of that like it's it's a
really cool thing Jim Jasper's is just
way too powerful for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because there's no
one there there's there's no conceivable
means of defeating him right like
there's there's no conceivable way of
defeating someone like that with powers
that extreme because the guy was
basically a walking talking God but let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section I'm kind of curious
like give me some characters that you
think are just like too powerful to
appear in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and like Marvel movies I'm really
curious to see what you guys come up
with because to me it's a cool idea
anyway if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rock core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later
purse
[Music]